Graci sonofabitch opera Barbara so
veinte Lavar bunchy and naraka burrows
such a very benign Cho it's a filler and
fantasy magnificus a preparation Ito is
a true
no no la fête egg or a michael ancher Oh
Sahara Norwich a la barriada Boone
dibidibidip Umbra pitcher pitcher
pitcher no la me forever dodo Jai une
spotted a Sephora monitor Bonaventure is
a cab adentro Caribbean soda fight a war
etc Fellini Futaba Navarro Jay Lee sofa
van Shalimar event Josephine - OH
true story is about Orion no sir for
China for Dawn of identity
bad scene II Clemenza Tattaglia for toda
la noche no super DJ no no no see photo
wrote a versatile Aaron called oh no sir
friend Annette asleep perfect
so if you're and called oh I'm here
because I was asked to to be the host of
this evening bye miss Lauren which meant
a great deal to me and she's an
incredible person just thinking about a
beauty can keep air traffic controllers
awake at night at brilliant actress she
was also one of the world's great sex
symbols she once said everything you see
io2 spaghetti well if that's true Joan
Rivers could have saved herself a lot of
money tonight we celebrate her career
for over six decades she's shown the
world a woman who was much more than
just gorgeous she can be funny
mysterious dramatic exciting naughty
profound heartbreaking Sophia's proof
that talent wants out because if you
have looks but no talent well then
you're on Celebrity Apprentice
she is the first performer to win an
Academy Award for a role in a language
other than English and yet Arnold
Schwarzenegger has none it's an amazing
career and a life story she grew up in a
little village and in Naples her family
faced hard times during World War two
but the age of about 14 her
extraordinary beauty led her to become a
finalist in a beauty contest which she
didn't win who won this thing is it easy
to for you to watch yourself do you like
watching yourself when I'm good
because I love watching yourself
well maybe I'm always good for you which
for you yeah this is the 50th
anniversary of two women and you were
not originally cast in in the mother's
role you were originally cast as the
daughter but you said no I should play
the mother on a minyan II was Claire
head cast as the mother rigidly yeah so
what you do it or in the back of the
head with a thing I had had how did you
end up in this part know the seeker when
he read the book he said that a man
Yanni would be perfect for the mother
and I would be perfect for the daughter
so he went to sea and Oman Yanni and she
said oh yes I love the story very much
but I prefer a little girl and otherwise
Sophie and myself we are going to eat
each other on the screen I don't know
why she thought that but because I'm not
that kind of a person but anyway she was
very unhappy if she if I wasn't fair so
they seek I said well I'm very sorry try
to convince her still with the telegrams
and things but she said no no no no no
no just you choose somebody else I was
in France I was doing a film with the
janga BAM
Victoria sent me a telegram saying don't
worry you are going to be cheesy which
is the name of the character if you
don't know she Zira and and a little
girl of 14 13 14 years old she's going
to be your daughter and I said by god
I'm not even I don't know I don't know
what to do what to do and so he said
don't worry don't worry we will be
together and I would we will be we will
do a wonderful picture together I'm sure
of it
so I said to myself if the seeker says
so I follow him and my life changed
completely so I have to say can avignon
it up and she said no no none because I
have not a bad person
no no no old were you when you met Carlo
Ponti well you were 14 15 and in this
was it this was at this beauty contest
that you finished second in yeah I
always finished second in the beauty
contest I don't know why
deciced I don't get this I don't get
well maybe I said maybe if you had one
you would have gone on to do something
else but other than I don't know if you
are so secure or what you say it should
tell me what I'm so far from secure I
don't even have a car that can drive me
to secure but he would change your life
because he believed in you as an actress
and and and your relationship with him
was a glorious one two beautiful sons
and he even talked to me how to eat well
this I have to hear no no I want to eat
because one day we went to a restaurant
and I ordered an anomaly and I picked up
the fork and the knife and he said don't
do that because because the omelet you
only cut it with a fork since then I
never ordered the omelet again